the hands-on boss so right now I'm gonna
check in with our director Billy Bala
Tino in his segment I'm calling checking
in with Billy hey Billy hey Conan what's
up
I just checking in ok for the talking
taco sketch am I looking at camera 2 or
camera 3
that's a great question Conan I'm gonna
have to ask one of the camera guys about
that in a new segment I'm calling check
the name with Marty hey Marty hey Billy
what's up I'm just checking in ok hey
for the talking taco sketched is Conan
look at camera 2 or camera 3 that's a
great question Billy and II wrote the
talking taco sketch so I'm gonna get
your answer in a new segment I'm calling
checking in with Andy Andy hey Marty
what's up just checking in ok for the
talking taco sketch does the Conan look
at camera 2 or camera 3 you know that's
a great question Marty and I'll be happy
to answer it on tonight's episode of
wait a minute Andy Andy what are you
doing just tell all I need to know is
which camera to welcome to getting back
to Marty I'm your host Andy Ritcher we
have got a great show tonight
my first guest is the host of Conan on
TBS
please welcome Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
great to have you okay welcome just Andy
just answer the question about the taco
sketch you look absolutely gorgeous
tonight okay just stop it all right
I want a figure eight we've just
scratched the surface we'll have a lot
more with Conan O'Brien after this
commercial break
tonight it's a very special getting back
to Marty he's beaten by a bear
[Music]
and we're back coming I also understand
that you brought a clip yeah yes I did
it's it's a clip it's a clip from my new
show called hey Andy stop being a dick
and just tell Marty which camera I'm
supposed to look at for the talking taco
sketch sounds great let's watch hey Andy
hey Conan what's up hey stop being a
dick and just tell Marty which camera
I'm supposed to look at in the talking
taco sketch okay Conan no problem hey
Marty hey Andy what's up I'm just
getting back to you okay camera three
camera three got it thank you great I'm
gonna let Billy know that Conan should
look at camera three in a new segment
I'm calling getting back to Billy
hey Billy hey Marty look out there's a
bear behind you and now I'm gonna know
that Marty is getting eaten by a bear in
a new segment I'm calling get them back
to Conan you know just no need to do
that Billy Billy no I can see the bear
we also Billy I already know what camera
to look at for the talking taco sketch
we figured it out oh oh that's good
because Marty is being eaten by a bear
no it's literally been happening right
in front of me
he took 20 minutes to creep up on him
turning I'm sorry but that's all the
time we have for getting back to Conan
until next time I'm Billy Barty now
saying goodnight and stay groovy America
yeah okay thank you a lot Billy after
okay you know after all that I don't
think we're gonna have time after all
for the talking taco sketch so I'm very
very sorry
talking taco you will all pay for this
with God as my witness I will get my
revenge
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
I I don't know why you people are
cheering there's a brutal belly rubbing
going on
Hey hey bear hey bear next time you're
gonna sneak up on someone start from
further back okay
[Music]